foreign
[Music]
low in the glow of the vending machine
you'll be the last to know
[Music]
rules
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hey fam so that's a location in DC that
I have been wanting to shoot at for
quite some time so I'm glad that the
star is finally aligned to make that
work this month that big red building
behind me in the video is actually the
National Building Museum which usually
hosts some of the most incredible
installation pieces that I get to see in
DC so it's pretty cool to get to shoot
outside of it
um real quickly I just want to put in a
huge thank you to flowtoys for
sponsoring this video and uh giving me a
reason to go outside and explore a lot
of the beautiful places in DC if you'd
like to grab a pair of those flow moja
uh contact POI that I was using in this
video you can do so by heading on over
to flowtoys.com and using the promo code
drexfactor 7 2023 at checkout that gets
you a discount on your order and it
helps out the channel so everybody wins
and yes the code is now changing on a
monthly basis so keep your eyes peeled
for the next code drop uh thanks once
again to flow toys uh also speaking of
thank yous big thanks to the Friends of
the channel that is big thanks to dark
monk fire Mecca flowfests flow toys
juggling calling pyro Terra light toys
spin balls and Ultra POI for helping
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business friend of the
channel That is Becca becklinen thank
you so much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission also this video
would not be possible were it not for
the kind support of all of these amazing
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon they and the
people listed down in the description
help to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible thank
you one and all for your very generous
support and if you out there watching
are not currently supporter but you'd
like to become one you you can do that
by heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards and even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring POI spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you if you
enjoyed this video and you'd like to
check out more videos of me performing
with a variety of different sets of poi
I will go ahead and leave a link to a
playlist of the different flow sessions
that I've recorded over the years down
in the description as well as up on
screen if you're watching on YouTube
also the YouTube algorithm thinks that
you might like this top video here
because it is popular amongst viewers of
my channel so maybe give that a look too
thanks so much for watching be sure to
get out and flow today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon
peace